to talk more about his upcoming cyber
thriller black cat please welcome mr.
Michael Mann
thank you for making this your first
comic-con this is a very special treat
thank you for having me I've heard so
much from my friends like your mother
taro about how wonderful this is and how
enthused enthusiastic audience is and
it's a great great pleasure to be here
so thanks guys so I'd love to before we
get started on blackhat I'd love to talk
a little bit more about your incredible
body of work you have titles like thief
Manhunter Heat Miami Vice Public Enemies
your work has really come to define the
modern crime drama can you give us a
little bit of insight on your process
and how you approach the psychology of
the criminal worlds one of the one of
the big benefits and one of the thrills
of doing what I do the work that I do is
that ability to immerse yourself into
the mill you into the characters into
the real people so I've always I've
always kind of you know rather than
derived something from other films about
the thief I'm gonna make a movie about a
thief I would want to meet a
professional thief and spend a lot of
time with professional thieves
bacala scientist at blackhat hackers so
that's yes there's that research
excursion that's that's always amazing
and I think that audiences I think you
know if it's done right and it impacts
the actors and I think all audiences are
very very smart they're smarter than
they than they know when they see a
character who feels authentic and
resonates in a certain way and they
could kind of tell the truth telling
style what they're what they're saying
now the threat in this movie is pretty
much ripped from today's headlines I
mean it's very very applicable
applicable to what we go through today
can you talk a little bit about the
digital underworld that the film taps
into well the the movie began with
legendary and Thomas tall Sanjay and
myself want to do a large-scale crime
story that in Asia and I had just come
back from Indonesia and Singapore and
then Stuxnet for those of you who know
what Stuxnet is
Stuxnet had just happened then there's a
lot of attention to how important
intrusions into in the cyber world and
so then I started to do research and
then wanted to make a film about a black
hat hacker who was in federal prison and
that took me right into the world of
what is the what is who is this guy what
is he what is he feel what's his what's
his elevated experience and it was
pretty stunning so I'm hanging with some
black that hackers and one of the things
you found out that when they got deep
into the experience of coding seven
eight hours of coding they kind of zoned
into it and that it's kind of a very
pleasurable op8 account of a feedback
loop and what was really interesting
about it is that it's a kind of escapism
but it's escapism in Reverse they don't
escape into a fantasy or fiction they
dig Zone in and escape into a place but
their impact of there
is in the real world it's in the
physical world though it's interesting
interesting thing to tackled what it
made was terrific to be able to bring
actors in the whole film into that into
their world now it is a little bit of a
tradition to bring something to Comic
Con so we'd love to see anything you
might have brought for black hats well
that's coincidentally we brought a
little something right here yes we did
so it's a first this is the first view
anybody's had of anything on the film
including let me take a look at it yeah
there's somebody who just kind of fell
by why accident passing through
maybe a little Crim's Hemsworth
how's it going so Chris what was it like
working with such an amazing director uh
was incredible I mean top ten favorite
movies that am on a lot of them come
from Michael last of Mohicans I've seen
a thousand times Pete and many others
and you know you hear Michael talk you
see the footage of seniors films and
there's no one that does the precision
and detail like him and and so work with
someone like that and had that body of
knowledge and information was just the
best experience I could have had
is it ever intimidating at all or yeah
absolutely every day you know thinking
maybe I could I could say there so this
instead and and look at him in it just
look at me and I'm good yeah might be
known we could just leave exactly the
way you brought it and probably perfect
yeah there's it's it's a luxury though
you know you don't get someone who does
I've never seen this kind of research we
went to a number of prisons to make
criminals and people yeah we had a day
as well one day which started at 4:00
a.m. at u.s. steel in Gary Indiana
because Chris's characters are son of a
steelworker who got into a my tennis
scholarship that's all backstory it's
not in the film yeah then later net day
is still dirty from the steel mill we
went through the scoreboard a trade
where things get hacked once in a while
and from there we went to Stateville
prison where natural-born killers were
shot if you remember that cylindrical
place and there was there was a normal
day of prep yeah human chair all types
of really yeah weird locations that's uh
yeah we did we did we did about 74
scenes and for foreign countries or four
countries and
66 days in 6 days 66 oh so tell me a
little bit about your character Nick
Hathaway because he you're no stranger
to action but he's a different type of
action he's he's more methodical and
thoughtful
yeah there's as an intelligence this guy
has that is kind of unmatched
to a lot of people in his world as far
as the cyber world goes he he but came
from a working-class background and was
working in a steel mill as Michael said
and had this kind of knowledge and this
this ability and then fell into
cybercrime and ended up on the wrong
side of the law and when we meet him in
the film he is pulled into a situation
or needed they need his assistance
because of the the skills he has and all
of a sudden he has an advantage on from
yeah he was in the past okay now you
guys started shooting around the time of
WikiLeaks and Edward Snowden when that
all started directing so how you know we
touched about a little bit on it before
but how do you feel that the film
reflects the age were living in today
it's you know we started researching
this and started working together and I
gotta say this - being a terrific actor
who's you know who's gonna have a great
career that's just beginning he's also a
terrific guy and a really regular fella
and you know if the stuff that's in the
headlines today was stuff that we kind
of research from our sources in
Washington another place is about two
years ago and so it's all kind of it's
all kind of breaking it's it is the
world we live in we live in this world
of kind of this exoskeleton of the
internet and connectedness and
everything is totally porous and that's
what everybody that is fearful and it's
kind of kind of where a lot of our a lot
of our drama happens we landed in Hong
Kong one day for Edward Snowden flew
from from China to Rosco oh wow that's
that's yeah I mean it's just we're in an
age now where literally
you don't even realize what you put up
there but anybody can find out where
you're married where you're located if
many kids your head your kids names it's
terrifying that was the big appeal or
the facet I should yeah yeah with Chris
yeah Chris well we either a guy a
mathematician Chris McKinley who
basically I had two months of computer
lessons and and working on how to talk
because I used to talk like this and now
it's like this and I'm working ahead
about code and and you know
understanding this world they're trying
to get a taste of it anyway and all of a
sudden you realize how vulnerable we are
in this age and you know that the
possibility is what you think is safe
from the information you think is is a
secret isn't and I was talking this guy
about what
you know what's possible he said yeah I
could just hack into your computer you
know through this network and pull out
all your photos and all your information
if I wanted or I could switch on the
camera into your your computer or your
phone and look at what's going on and
and you start to sort of understand the
possibilities and all of a sudden I was
like let's get rid of my computer and
I'm turning my phone off and don't have
Wi-Fi on them and put it inside the
camera but Chris had Chris was wearing a
vest you got his PhD from UCLA but in he
was he wanted to go to you want to meet
a girl so he could be honest this is not
maple that he had hacked into a hacked
into a dating service and picked the
girls he liked and became the ideal male
for about thirty five of those girls and
he said he what he hacked into his web
design worked out like what was it that
made the ideal profile the most
consistent one and he said it was a
person holding a child looking away from
camera and I said I so you don't have a
kid so did you make your profile pic
with someone else's kid he said no used
an animal I was like surely that's got
to be different in some way you know and
send a different message but he did this
thing in Hackney and all of a sudden
went from having one coffee date a week
to like ten dates a day
and had to schedule just like brief
meetings and things and had it was the
most saleable guy on this website and
all through packing the system you can't
blame them but that is creepy
that is creepy I mean but also weird
terrifying so the movie comes out
January 16th of next year thank you guys
so much for coming guys big mouth thank
you very much
you
you